ein euro jeder von euch hat
wahrscheinlich schon mal so eine münze
in der hand und so ein euro ist
eigentlich schneller ausgegeben als man
gucken kann man holt sich irgendwie an
der tankstelle packung kaugummis oder
schnell was zu trinken dann ist so eine
euro schon weg die frage die ich mir
gestellt habe ist kann man mit so einem
euro einen gesamten tag ist drei
gerichte drei mahlzeiten und das
allerwichtigste satt werden dabei ich
sage mal so viel das einkaufen ist mit
der schwerste partnerin wir haben es uns
viel zu einfach vorgestellt wir sind
einen großen supermarkt gegangen haben
gedacht okay hier ist ein relativ
niedriges preisniveau
jetzt holen wir uns einzelne karotte
einzelnen champignons was auch immer
erst das problem ist gibt es auch nicht
einzeln dann hast du direkt ein paket
champignons zum beispiel für 1 euro 50
geht nicht dann guckt man sich um was
ist hier eigentlich günstig und man
stellt fest eigentlich alles würde hier
das budget sprengen also science ein
paar tomaten klein coll kopfsalat
geschweige denn tierische produkte die
sie natürlich mit recht alle noch mal
teurer als obst gemüse und getreide oder
was auch immer deshalb bin ich drauf los
gezogen und dachte mir was ist nahrhaft
das kann man zum frühstück essen womit
man gesättigt ist was anhält
haferflocken eine packung haferflocken
kostet aber bisschen weniger als 1 euro
vielleicht 50 cent aufwärts damit wenn
man ein ganzes budget eigentlich schon
verplant um glück habe ich einen
unverpackte segment im supermarkt
gefunden und konnte mir dort 100 gramm
haferflocken kaufen für 17 cent und das
sollte es eigentlich schon fast gewesen
sein vom ersten supermarkt bis wir dann
kurz vor der kasse ein ich bin noch gut
regal gefunden haben wo reduzierte
lebensmittel zu finden sind und dort
haben wir ein schabbat gefunden ein brot
welches von 79 auf 39 cent reduziert war
und ich dachte mir okay das könnte
funktionieren aber was ist man auch so
ein brot raus aus dem supermarkt ab in
den nächsten monaten nichts gefunden
haben das war ein premium supermarkt
keine chance keinen billigen produkte
direkt wieder raus ab in den discounter
wo wir eine karotte gekauft haben dachte
mir so ein bisschen salz bisschen
pfeffer auf dem brot kommt gut ist wieso
alternative brust ketter wir haben ja
haferflocken gekauft aber haare flocken
mit wasser einfach so ist wirklich schon
übel soll ich will ja klar über den tag
kommen aber ich will auch mich nicht
ecke wird dem essen deshalb haben wir
einen weiteren supermarkt und haben dort
eine günstige banane gefunden aber wir
haben gestern so ein bisschen uns
umgeschaut da gab es dieselben dann 50
rabatt ein bisschen braun warnt jetzt
haben wir eine die eigentlich zu jung
ist aber trotzdem 14 cent wenn die
banane ist schon wirklich sehr gut so
zwei mahlzeiten stehen wir haben das
brot und wir wollen nicht schon wieder
einfach nur rot mit irgendwas essen dann
haben wir einen kiosk gesehen bei dem
man einzelne zwiebeln kaufen konnte und
haben uns gedacht noch mal brot mit
zwiebeln wer irgendwie nicht so das
wahre deshalb machen wir eine brot
zwiebelsuppe und haben somit das letzte
unserer drei gerichte gefunden und
müssen jetzt eigentlich nur noch
anfangen zu kochen jetzt gibt es nur
noch zwei fragen werde ich satt und wird
das ganze auch schmecken können wir es
drauf ganz grundsätzlich um die regeln
abzuklären in einem haushalt hat man ja
gewisse dinge einfach da so die man
nicht auch alles auch rechnet und
beispielsweise gewürze kräuter die ich
auf dem balkon haben wachsen ja sogar
von selbst nach so ich werde davon
geringe mengen verwenden aber ich darf
jetzt nur geschafft also nicht wo 100
milliliter öl in mein brot machen und
dann bin ich so also das ist nicht der
sinn der sache aber haushaltsübliche
mengen von öl zum braten zum würzen
sonstwas benutze ich klar das hebt
eigentlich den preis auch wenn man es
anteile grund rechnet aber dafür habe
ich halt h verführung zum beispiel so
gekauft denk mal los wir legen los wir
nehmen fein ist das leitungswasser das
wird übrigens abgesichert keine getränke
gekauft auch mein einziges getränk für
den heutigen tag vom
hersteller so banale dies leider
eigentlich noch ein bisschen zu unreif
also man würde sie eigentlich noch
liegen lassen wo es jetzt durch das ding
ist die liebe ja eh nicht so ultra
übernahmen wegen ihrer konsistenz und
wenn sie noch jung sind dann sind sie
weniger schleimig so ich schneide das
mal die ganze banane entscheiden werde
aber dann nur die hälfte davon als
topping benutzen ich finde es wirklich
krass dass wissenschaft haben verein
lasst uns auch nicht geglaubt und ich
war so wirklich im laden ich habe
fünfmal abgebrochen du hast auf über
projekt will das schon hin also ich
finds auch krass und ich bin jetzt
höchst gespannt schmeckt das nach was
wenn das wasser einmal aufgekommen ist
gehen wir auch schon unsere hertha block
entdeckt jedes mal folgt immer nur mit
milch gemacht deshalb ist es für mich
jetzt gerade bisschen traurig aber eric
meinte dass das durchaus messen ist weil
welches fitness bewusst personen sich
mal reingehen ich sagte wie es ist das
riecht lecker das nicht super ja es
schmeckt halt jetzt gerade noch nach
überhaupt gar nichts da werden wir jetzt
unsere banale einrühren und dann am ende
darüber geben sieht das bestimmt schon
anderes also problem ist dadurch das
hier ist nicht super reif ist es hier
natürlich auch nicht super süß aber das
4 1 und das war's dann auch schon wenn
jetzt noch liebevoll garnieren und dann
hoffe ich dass ein bisschen speck
zumindest
sieht nicht schlecht aus also sie
wirklich nicht schlecht aus für mich ist
macht optisch gar keinen großen
unterschied ob man das heute milch macht
es ist eine schwere folge schüssel und
rein von den mehrwerten her wenn ich mir
wirklich relativ sicher dass mich das
machen wird jetzt gucken wir mal was
auch spaß macht dabei mitzumachen aus
gut schmeckt obwohl bekommen
reife banane ja schon gut gewesen alter
wirklich dies noch super jungen die
banane dementsprechend ist da wirklich
kaum süße auszuziehen und die textur ist
jetzt auch nicht erwartet ich muss
wirklich sagen ich hab schon sachen
gegessen
die waren ähnlich
wenn du so ein bisschen auf fitness
gehst und so wissen funktional ist
sodann ist du halt durch auch sowas nach
seiner beschreibung vier von zehn 43
oder vier von zehn euro das ist halt
nichts aber es ist ja auch funktional
sowas ist ja selbst um in diesen rahmen
zu kommen und daran gemessen
funktioniert ist und ich bin mir sicher
dass erst heute mittag wieder hunger das
ding ist hier das wasser durch milch
gibt ein bisschen honig dazu bisschen
zimt oder das ist richtig gut und es ist
trotzdem noch günstig du bist ja nach
der arbeit kommt das vergnügen auf diese
mine eurovideo
1500 und vielleicht noch weitere aber
damit die anderen videos funktionieren
konnten wir nicht runter rechnen ich
konnte jetzt nicht sagen okay ich nehmen
ein zehntel von der packung haferflocken
und das kostet mich dann 5,9 cent weil
dann hätte ich ja nächste video werde
ich irgendwo super teures produkt nehme
genauso dritteln können und dann jetzt
alles keinen sinn mehr machen das ist
durch die echte challenge und beim
frühstück punkten jetzt echt gut wir
kommen zum mittagessen und ich muss
sagen ich habe die der hunger nicht
gerade knapp ich habe auch mal ein
bisschen rum gerechnete kalorien
technisch ist das schon knapp bemessen
heute also es ist ein diät tag so das
system geschuldet dass wir eine
abwechslung rein bringen wollen weil ich
hätte den kalorienbedarf decken können
indem ich einfach packung haferflocken
kaufen und die mit wasser ist das wollte
ich nicht das video nicht und für mich
selbst nicht aber wir machen heute diät
auf jeden fall und die setzen wir fort
mit unserer sucht dafür müssen wir
erstmal das brot aufbacken bisschen nass
gemacht 200 grad im ofen und wir packen
das ganze für zehn bis zwölf minuten auf
während das schafft einen ofen backt
bereiten wir die zwiebel vor und
verschwenden dabei so wenig wie es nur
irgendwie geht
zwiebeln schneiden brot ist fertig und
ein bisschen abgekühlt wir sie zwiebeln
geschnitten das heißt wir machen den
herd an ihm ein wenig olivenöl
hineinnehmen also zwiebeln im topf mit
unserem brot mache ich folgendes ich
halbiere ist die hälfte werden wir heute
abend essen
und jetzt hatte ich ein paar dünne
scheiben davon da gibt jetzt auch ein
wenig olivenöl dran wollen wir uns ein
wenig groß marie 40 euro diese
rosensträucher habe ich mir vor einem
jahr geholt einmal bezahlt und seitdem
wächst das nach was das geld 0 euro
dafür ist in rosmarin dran und da warten
wir jetzt mal so weitere zehn minuten
bis sie wie man es halt kennt so richtig
schön knusprig sind wer ist von unserem
brot schneiden mit ebenfalls klein und
das gibt weiß so die seligkeit für die
software so ist jetzt ein bisschen
komisch sieht ein bisschen komisch aus
aber wir müssen halt bisschen
improvisieren alles ein bisschen
eingerostet und jetzt geben wir das
wasser drauf
und so können wir das ganze jetzt für
zehn minuten rot apps sind fertig und
unsere suppe in der gleichen zeit auf
reparieren das ganze
muss wirklich einmal kräftig daran
gegangen werden mit salz und pfeffer
bisschen flüssig vielleicht
also ich muss wirklich sagen das ist
eine stolze portion geworden es ist am
ende des tages trotzdem genau dass der
teil road randy reingemacht habe das
würde nicht mehr dadurch dass ich mehr
wasser angeben aber was hat fühlt auf
jeden fall also man bildet sich bestimmt
eine durch gesättigt dazu sein dass
jetzt nicht ultra dick aber ich nehme
mal so mit so einem kosten löffel
das toppt löst oft recht also die olive
macht liebe macht sehr viel das brot
sorgt dafür dass im mund wirklich so das
gefühl von so einer schönen cremigen
super hast gerade mit dem roman den ich
jetzt habe es ist ein recht gutes essen
also für auf meiner sucht muskalla bin
ich so zwischen 7 5 und 8 den teller
suppe ist fast auf gewährt und muss
wirklich sagen jetzt für den moment
nicht schmeckt immer noch gut aber ich
muss nicht so weiter weil jetzt gerade
wenig gefüllt so ich bin mir sicher wie
lange das anhält weil glaube niemand von
euch bestellt sich wenn er hungrig ist
im restaurant eine suppe so das muss man
schon dazu sagt aber geschmacklich war
das richtig gut und es ist mit
sicherheit auch wieder nichts was
irgendwie schwer im magen liegt oder
sohn also man bleibt einfach fresh ich
wahrscheinlich erst das jetzt auch da
sehen wir uns zum abendessen und ich
hoffe dass es mich sagt was soll ich
sagen du bist form einer halben stunde
war ich ja eigentlich echt noch gut
gesättigt also es ist nicht zu
vergleichen mit einer riesigen portion
reis mit beilage und so alle möglich das
ist es nicht so aber ich war gesättigt
und das hat seinen zweck erfüllt jetzt
habe ich aber wieder wirklich hunger und
einem normalen tag werde ich jetzt
vielleicht ein bisschen traurig darüber
dass jetzt wieder mit dem brot
weitermache aber dadurch dass wir einen
super gemacht haben also wirklich lecker
die suppe haben wir eigentlich ein
anderes recht so haben zwar die gleiche
grundlage aber was ich jetzt mache super
sind will fahne an wir halbieren unser
büro und jetzt geben wir hier quasi
wenig olivenöl braucht posten das an das
könnte wahrscheinlich dann das
einfachste rezept sein was ich jemals
gezeigt habe
ich schneide jetzt oben unten habe ich
will das nicht mal so großartig weil
passiert eh nicht sicher was ein mal
schnellster und die straße dich jetzt
einfach
sagt ehrlich das wäre auch sonst legen
das würde noch krasser werden wenn man
irgendwie so ein bisschen täter käse
wahllos bisschen zitronensäure bisschen
honig nochmal drüber machen könnte dann
wäre das schon ganz ganz krankes brot
aber so wie wir mit wenig geld und das
ist gar nicht nur wenig wirklich gut
bedient diese mahlzeit jetzt vom abend
ich wollte eigentlich nicht sagen aber
das ist schon eher eine funktionale
wahlzeit oder ich bin gespannt heiter
ich sagte ehrlich ich kann mir irgendwie
vorstellen wenn wir das schön knusprig
bekommen es wird jetzt keinen kein
kranker gaumenschmaus aber endlos wird
nicht scheiße und jetzt mache ich mir
ganz einfach war dann probieren wir mal
unsere kreationen kurzer prozess
ich hatte mich gar nicht vorstellen auf
der zunge
hat man so auf jeden fall noch nicht
gegessen so das kann man glaube ich
ziemlich sicher sagen dass man probieren
das ist sowas so die ultra hat auch
fleischesser sich vorstellen was veganer
essen jeden tag mit krawatte
das frühstück hat halt noch so wenig
geschmeckt das ist sehr geschmackvoll
aber es ist halt eine außergewöhnliche
geschmackskombinationen aber eine die
wirklich mit den ergänzungen die ich
gesagt habe war
schaafs käse das würde es so krass
kommen wirklich ich bleibe aber glaub
ich dabei dass das mittagessen wir am
besten geschmeckt hat nichtsdestotrotz
dass es sich jetzt heute abend zwei
große brote und ich weiß schon fast ein
bisschen dass ich dann nicht so komplett
gesättigt und befriedigt zurückbleiben
werde deshalb ich würde sagen challenge
bestanden so ich habe mich einen tag nur
für sogar weniger als 1 euro ernährt ich
hatte abwechslung drin ich habe sachen
wir gästen die lecker waren aber so wie
ich jetzt eingekauft habe würde das
wahrscheinlich nach ein paar tagen bis
an die substanz gehen weil es ein
bisschen zu wenig ist wenn man aber sagt
man machten die e tag und will dabei
noch jede menge kohle sparen bekommt das
was ich heute gekocht habe so leute ich
freue mich freue mich auch auf die
nächsten videos auf die nächsten stufen
unserer reise danke fürs zuschauen bis
zum nächsten mal